[Music]  you guys will watch the People's Court  I'm sure you've seen it one time or  another well there's a new version of  the People's Court on TV for people who  like courtroom reality shows but hate  all the fighting and bickering they  don't like that part  so they've edited this new show down so  there's no quarreling I think this new  version is really going to take off they  look chill moley Kapur tomorrow  busca ash garnish meal and Hassan Karim  Ishmael Michael of Bob you can teemoshi  Michelle Hussey and her daughter  Elizabeth marcin athena Steven to manaro  axel Rodriguez Michael Ferrari and Megan  Campbell  [Applause]  watch it for hours well though they all  have their crappy folder the Royal  window broke right it's in this folder  yeah that's all I need  yeah this is this is justice here